Zac: Alright dude, what'd I miss?
Bryce: OK, so they just drove down the field, third and long in the red zone.
Zac: Alright, here we go.
Bryce: Here we go man.
Oh oh OH OH!!
Bryce: What is that?
Zac: What just happened?
Zac: Where's the remote?
Bryce: We gotta see playback. Where is the remote?
TV: Now the crab people, they're real.
Bryce: Jeez, I can't believe we missed it...
Zac: Oh wait, here's a replay.
Aww! What?
Zac: What? Where is the remote?
Bryce: Dude, what is going on with your TV?
Dude, just go up to the TV and switch it again.
TV: What time is it? It's like...
Gosh, this is so stupid. What's wrong with your TV?
Zac: Alright, where are we?
Bryce: I don't know, it's just...
Zac: What is this?
Bryce: What?
Zac: Alright, you know what? We're going to Joey's place. We're gonna watch the game at Joey's place.
Bryce: Alright. Let's go to Joeys...
Zac: I hate Joey...
Zac: Catch you later Joey.
Bryce: See you Joe.
Bryce: See you later man.
Zac: See you next week.
Bryce: Alright. Good luck finding that remote.
*static*
Uhh.... Where is the remote...?
Thanks for watching Remote Threat. Head on over to Kendall Zebidiah's channel for some amazing sketch comedy sketches.
And if you liked the video remember to like this video and subscribe for awesome horror shorts every other week.
And we'll see you in the next one. Assuming we both survive.
Oh jeez. I wonder what could happen.
*SCREAMING*